aumenta la presión contra las
plataformas de criptomonedas justo un
día después de demandar a binance la
comisión de bolsa y valores de Estados
Unidos tiene en la mira a coinbase la
mayor bolsa de criptomonedas del país
por operar presuntamente como corredor
no registrado coinbase será plenamente
consciente de la aplicabilidad de las
leyes federales de valores a sus
actividades comerciales pero
deliberadamente se negó a seguirlas si
bien las decisiones calculadas de
coinbase pueden haberle permitido ganar
miles de millones lo ha hecho expensas
de los inversores privandoles de las
protecciones a las que tienen derecho
coinbase contraatacó culpando al enfoque
de los reguladores la confianza de la
sec en un enfoque basado únicamente en
la aplicación de la ley en ausencia de
normas claras para el sector de los
activos digitales está perjudicando a la
competitividad económica de Estados
Unidos y a empresas como coinbase que
han demostrado su compromiso con el
cumplimiento Mientras tanto binance la
mayor bolsa de criptomonedas del mundo y
su fundador fueron acusados comunes de
gestionar una bolsa ilegal en Estados
Unidos y de engañar a los inversores
vainas ha argumentado durante mucho
tiempo que no está sujeta a las leyes
estadounidenses porque no tiene una sede
física en el país sin embargo Estados
Unidos reforzó su control sobre las
plataformas de criptomonedas
especialmente desde la quiebra de ftx en
noviembre del año pasado la Unión
Europea también promulgó recientemente
una ley histórica con normas para este
sector